little mess I'm just trying to be every
day oh stop it I sort of got here
Instagram I was like who I'm gonna make
a baby now yeah it's time drill chick
Todd hi everyone's like where's the baby
I'm like whoa well remember when I saw
you and it you first found out I was
pregnant you were like I want a baby so
fast yes you know how long I wanted it
I'll call you immediately if it's a
positive sign but like we go on and off
we're like let's do it now and they were
like let's wait till door you know y'all
try it no but we tried for like one
second and I was like just get it don't
you know like I don't know I keep
getting ever since I saw you and I was
like I want it now come over and play
I'm gonna do that I'll do that yeah well
you look amazing let's talk that thank
you it is a custom dress by Christian
Siriano
oh no Siriano Christian Siriano it's a
custom by Christian Siriano and my
jewelry is forever Marc that's right
yeah yes diamond diamonds oh my god you
got me yes speed round
describe your look in one word power the
secret about your own okay my secret
about my outfit oh there's so much duct
tape on my chest right now
craziest the most painful thing you did
to fit into the other the duct tape
because they had to real redo it several
times so that definitely hurts and it's
gonna be taking off later - Bob borrowed
or stolen do any of those apply to this
uh he made it for me so I think I bought
it I don't think yeah and are the
diamonds borrow their borrowed borrowed
uh first thing you're gonna do or eat
when you get out of that pizza that's my
reward every year is my tradition okay
so I haven't seen you
since you tie the knot congratulations
the band I picked it on myself
thank you yes it does it feels like whoa
look at this back off you know what I
mean
watch out you know The Love Train it's
out I'm so glad everyone's loving it and
they're bumping it
they already learned all the words my
fans are crazy they're great they really
are now for Valentine's Day I have to
ask you before I let you go we've heard
your story with Darryl tell me a little
bit about how you guys met again let's
get him in here and how you guys are
celebrating balance he was thinking of
him we're gonna be on a plane we're
gonna celebrate it a different day yeah
and he's he's already starting with the
gifts they're already coming in the mail
and he's like testing opens my mail so
some surprises his eyes you know I
thought what says is mine
[Music]